Johnny is with us in Fort Bragg North
Carolina hi Johnny how are you
hi Dave how are you doing better than I
deserve sir how can we help
good hey I was calling I have a couple
questions the first one is if I have a
loan with an interest rate of less than
one percent
why does it make sense to attack that
loan and and try to get rid of that debt
when I could use the minimum payments
and not have to pay a lot of interest
and put the extra money for my income
into a savings account with a higher
return or a uh Roth IRA or some sort of
retirement plan where I'm going to be
getting you know 10 return or higher if
I was doing like investing and stuff
okay and so how old are you
I'm 28 and a little bit of my background
um I went to the I went to the United
States Military Academy I got kicked out
and luckily didn't have to pay back
everything and I enlisted
um but I still have that loan payment so
I'm my income's around 2100 a month and
uh
uh my loan my minimum loan payments is
618 and it was originally thirty six
thousand dollar loan I got it down to
about
10-5 so good for you ten thousand five
hundred dollars good for you okay well
it's it's a really good question and
it's asked by a lot of people and um it
took me a little while to understand the
answer when I went broke and lost
everything because I had too much debt
uh my first part of my journey was
through a faith lens because I had uh
all these letters and licenses and
degrees after my name all about finances
said I was supposed to know something
about money but there I was bankrupt so
apparently I was a doofus right and so I
started approaching things first through
the faith lens and I read in the Bible
that the borrower is slave to the lender
and I started learning from Christian
teachers that the Bible doesn't have
anything good to say about debt so if
God doesn't like debt why would I okay
so I quit I don't borrow money and I I
and I did it on that basis alone over
the years that was 30 years ago over the
years I also have approached it through
the lens of mathematics or Academia uh
and uh so here's what I have discovered
when you say all right I could invest in
a mutual fund at 12 why would I ever pay
off my house at three percent at because
I could use that money and invest it at
12 or 11 or whatever and I'm going to
make an eight or a nine percent spread
and that's the essence of your question
isn't it
yeah I guess you know talking about a
house or something or whatever whatever
whatever the debt anytime I can borrow
money at a cheaper rate than I can
invest it why would I ever not do that
as much as I can do it
okay yeah and the way to the way to
explore that and answer that sometimes
is scale something and see if your idea
works with scale and so if you could
borrow 50 million dollars and go in debt
50 million dollars in order to invest
that money
and make the spread would you do it and
it kind of that causes your heart to
stop a second you go get a little a
little tightness in your throat and your
stomach if if you're if you're mature
anyway your stomach starts to move up
towards your throat you think you want
to throw up when I put scale to the idea
it scares you why does it scare you
because there's risk
and risk was left out of your formula
okay right and so and the honest truth
is there's actual mathematical ways to
insert risk into the formula let me give
you a little lesson here on mutual funds
okay an aggressive growth stock mutual
fund is very volatile if you were to map
it it goes way up and way down like a
super crazy roller coaster the
difference in the top of that mountain
in the bottom of that Valley
mathematically in a statistical measure
is called a beta the greater the beta
the greater the volatility the greater
the risk of the mutual fund and so if
you have an aggressive growth stock
mutual fund with a beta of two which
will take your breath away or you have
an uh and it makes a 26 percent rate of
return you do not compare that if you
are sophisticated Apples to Apples with
a growth in income mutual fund which has
a beta of a 0.5 meaning the Kitty roller
coaster
okay right and so you don't compare 26
percent with 12 percent without
adjusting for risk and you use an
inverse formula in mathematics with that
beta and adjust for risk and then you
can measure these things accurately
against each other risk adjusted you
have no risk adjustment in your formula
so your formula is wrong
well I understand that okay so don't
borrow money
because you're not risk adjusting on
your theoretical concept and you're
making twenty two hundred dollars or
Twenty One hundred dollars a month and
the second piece of data that you want
to do is the study that we did here and
as we studied millionaires Christy and
we stayed ten thousand one hundred sixty
seven millionaires we did not find any
of them that said the way I became a
millionaire was by not paying off low
interest debt and investing the money
yeah not a single one yeah out of ten
thousand one hundred sixty seven that we
interviewed and they were Ramsey
Millionaires and white space
millionaires meaning they don't even
know who I am or we are and so if real
millionaires aren't doing that to become
wealthy and your formula is wrong both
of those things tell you don't do this
crap yeah I think people get caught up
in the math and it's not that the math
is not important enough in the math the
the it's about the motivation the
momentum of one thing at a time I'm in
the baby steps the other thing I want
you to account for and you talked about
this with wrist Dave the thing that I
think people Miss is
in debt any type of debt with the risk
you're losing power and control and
options when you own things when you
save and put your money in savings when
you are debt free then you have more
power more control and more options and
everything we teach is about increasing
your power and control and decreasing
your risk because when you do you
increase your probability of becoming
wealthy yes and you don't have to start
over again like I did because I was
stupid and deeply in debt right and so
you owe anyone anything you know I never
my risk meter was broken I think when
they get you in the real estate business
they take a hammer to your risk meter
and just break it
because all these Real Estate Investors
they don't even they do not perceive the
risk of the leverage yeah and they just
buy you know we had all these seminars
going on in the 80s nothing down real
estate the guy went chapter 11 that
wrote the book you know yeah and so um
you know and all these uh surrendered a
guy that I had forgotten the name there
was a uh nothing down seminar on TV on
the first infomercial was a guy named
Dave Delgado okay and I ran into him at
this bit he owns a big house in Cabo
when I was visiting down there the other
day and it's like he and he has a big
Winery and all this stuff but he made
all his money from the infomercial not
from Real Estate
it's uh yeah I don't I mean real
estate's fine but here's the thing that
is not the shortest path to wealth
because of the risk factor that's what
it comes down to Johnny you can try it
and be a hard head if you want but
that's the answer to the question this
is the Ramsay show